caution natural gas this pumping station
in Poland is soon to go online German
utilities company rwe will be using it
to supply Ukraine with more natural gas
from Western Europe it will put a dent
in the monopoly Russian energy giant
Gazprom has had so far in Ukraine but
energy market expert andreas neck
wouldn't say it'll break the former
Soviet republics dependence on Russian
gas it is small this is about one half
billion cubic meters a year this is
nothing with when you compare with the
impulse from russia with a input about
30 billion cubic meters so it is about
five percent of the imports from russia
across the border in Ukraine this
facility near the city of levive belongs
to the state natural gas supplier
naftogaz this is the first time Western
reporters have been allowed up close to
the pipelines rwe sends the gas from the
station in Poland to underground storage
tanks here aircraft engines create the
pressure needed to transport at long
distances rwe has the capacity to meet
some twenty percent of Ukraine's yearly
gas demand with supplies from the West
but it would have to use the largest
east-west pipeline which runs through
Slovakia that would involve reversing
the direction so the gas would flow from
west to east which will present a
time-consuming but easily workable
technological challenge
naftogaz engineers are confident that
they could make the necessary
conversions in a few weeks the reporters
asked the head of the pumping station
how much gas rwe is currently sending
through here what was what I can't
answer that
okay not that question
the figures apparently have a sensitive
political aspect the barricades on the
Maidan in Kiev are still standing Russia
has been steadily increasing the
pressure on Ukraine's interim government
Gazprom has even threatened to halt
supplies completely RW ease natural gas
supplies could give Ukraine's battered
economy some badly needed security but
naftogaz chairman says Gazprom has
already forced all this eventualities
with special clauses in its contracts
blocking gas imports from the West they
have a signed document contract with
slovakian operator which prohibits such
a plate from changing gas reverse flow
in the direction of Ukraine and there is
no technical limitations or restrictions
in just a few legal restriction on
slovakian attracted to the soul Russia's
Gazprom is not giving up its monopoly
that easily meanwhile Ukrainians are
beginning to worry that they may not
have enough gas to heat their homes next
winter the heat and hot water from the
mining town sosnoff occur come from a
central gas fired heating plant the
plant is over 40 years old and very
inefficient the boiler woman complains
it supplies hot water to half the town
including two hospitals
obsolete gas furnaces are in use all
over Ukraine they keep gas consumption
high and help ensure Ukraine's continued
dependence on Russian gas imports to new
gas furnaces have been sitting here for
years waiting for their installation
they would save up to fifty percent
Martha Schwartzman in 2008 could have
cost about forty thousand euros to
install the furnaces now the government
doesn't have the cash to subsidize the
work needed to get them operating south
nika is just waiting for better times
the jungle butchy we will solutions have
to be found now while the weather's warm
not just for this plant but for the
whole country if the gas isn't
forthcoming it's going to be a cold
winter in Ukraine